dann ziehen doch jetzt einfach mal das
tuch beiseite auf 312
das kit zuletzt willkommen zu einem
video auf dass ich lange gewartet habe
lange lange lange lange debattiert das
ist das große mysterium das ist heute zu
erhöhen gilt das heute mit dhl kam und
ich freue mich wie ein kleines kind man
das ist wunderschön und wird sagen
ziehen doch jetzt einfach mal das buch
bei seite auf 3 125 ccm 1
wir machen jetzt erstmal so ein viertes
kleines unboxing-video immer noch nicht
ganz sicher über das mit der
kameraperspektive am besten machen aber
höchst beruf soll ich mal wenn ihr ein
bisschen nach oben besser da muss ich
weiter nach herzfeld enteilt erstmal
habe ich ein messer mit mir messen
können
alles klar erstmal hier oben auf machen
wir selbst auch gar nicht aufgemacht
machen das jetzt gerade zusammen mit rot
würdig trainieren ich hoffe fest sich um
mikro steht ein bisschen wacklig
es ist aber auch der kameraperspektive
aber es geht ja heute mich deswegen
achtet richtig die kamera einfach mehr
auf den pc kommt jetzt natürlich
leute eine sache noch ich wollte
eigentlich will den pc auf jeden fall
einen namen geben und ich habe bisher
noch irgendwie nicht so die kassen ein
für mich gefragt so was wie spartakus
wäre cool
schreibt man die kommentare was ihr von
spartacus haltet falls wieder nichts
dagegen haben dann heißt es finger wird
spartacus falls doch als es auf sparkurs
nicht was wir können auch gerne mal eure
vorschläge in die kommentare spanier
coole ideen ab dann könnte der name von
meinem pc vielleicht von dir rufen oder
von dir so muss das sein leute so muss
das sein
die kammer noch mal darunter machen mit
denen er nach vorne und jetzt jetzt gilt
es zum rückruf
wir hoffen dass jetzt am besten daraus
wohl fällt auf jeden fall schwer
sieht fast so aus als müssten einen
karton kaputt machen das haben wir hier
erst mal super toll davis windows
anbieter wie machen wir das am
geschicktesten okay okay hier ist
irgendwie mysteriöses kabeln das gut ist
mein gott endlich da ist dann wie aus
dem ei gepellt
der spartakus trolley man ihn nennen
wird in seiner glorreichen zukunft auf
diesem planeten zusammenarbeit mit mir
hier eine ganz neue phobie wunderschön
wunderschönen wunderschön
da ist ja geil geil geil geil geil ich
werde jetzt erstmal versuchen den
anzuschließen und dann vielleicht noch
paar bilder liefern wie er so läuft
jeden fall habe ich das video euch
gefallen dieses kleine unboxing von
meinem neuen pc habe mich so gefreut und
wollte es einfach mal teil mit euch
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann könnte
doch mal gerne ein leichter lassen ihr
wisst ihr wie es ist und in die
kommentare schreiben
will heißen soll dass eure ideen sind
und vielleicht wird der pc auf den namen
getauft in ihr vorschlag wenn er gut ist
wir sind aber im nächsten video wieder
macht gut haut rein und